à l'entrée du château le message est
déjà passé les visiteurs arrivent avec
leur masque sur le visage
en ce premier jour d'ouverture poste
confinement ils sont peu nombreux à
déambuler dans les vastes pièces et sur
les terrasses de la demeure de chasse de
françois 1er
je voulais voir le château et je voulais
prendre des photos en fait
cent personnes en sept dans le château
donc c'est c'est l'idéal
et cette réouverture un jour de semaine
n'est pas le fruit du hasard
on a choisi un jour de petite
fréquentation pour pouvoir se roder il
faut se mettre aussi à la plage de tous
nos agents on reprend le travail
on a de nouvelles mesures sanitaires
qu'on doit faire respecter il faut
vérifier que ça marche bien et peut-être
que ce week-end sera de plus forte
fréquentation
à l'extérieur on termine la toilette des
jardins à la française pendant qu'à
l'intérieur
le personnel lustres une dernière fois
les tomettes ce couple venu du nord de
la france tente de s'adapter à la
situation
c'est la première visite avec masque
bien que sur nos lieux de travail on les
employés et donc en fait quand c'est
assez surprenant c'est même j'irai
pratiquement originale parce qu'on va
tous les dispositifs de sécurité qui a
été mis en place
et bien ça nous convient on va bien vu
que à chambord il prenait étaient
nécessaires utiles et incontournable
quoi c'est pas naturel
elle ne masque pas naturel donc on verra
c'est une première masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur du château bornes hydro
alcoolique et tablettes pour les visites
tout est prévu pour que le visiteur soit
en sécurité
léonard de vinci lui même ya mis du sien
avec son célèbre escalier à double
révolution qui permet de monter et
descendre sans se croiser pour la
direction du château
le défi est de taille on sait qu'on perd
l'essentiel de la fréquentation
internationale au mois de juin on sait
qu'on perd tous les groupes scolaires on
perd les groupes de seniors
donc on s'attend pas à faire un bon mois
de juin on s'attend sur l'année à perdre
probablement la moitié de la
fréquentation
la moitié des recettes mais on espère
malgré tout que nos compatriotes
voudront venir à chambord voudront
visiter leurs lieux de patrimoine 2020
restera ici comme une année noire 9
millions de pertes attendues pour un
budget de fonctionnement de 18
millions d'euros